I think what people don't realize is that even in your 30s,...
...we're still just getting started.
Totally.
There's only one way to live and it's forward...
...and every year I'm celebrating that I'm alive...
...and you can't do this thing backwards...
...so I'm embracing everything that comes with it.
People always ask me, "How are you so confident?"
I'm like, this didn't happen overnight,...
....it's like, it took me 30 years to be so comfortable in my own skin.
As much as we are like, "Ooh, we've made it,..."
"...we're past age pressure."
It's like, we're still gonna have those feelings...
...because it's programmed in us to have them.
But now, we have the tools to deal with them in a healthier manner...
...instead of crumbling under that pressure...
...and having it dictate your life.